[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
this
man betrayed our trust
you've saved my life we are going home
i don't have a home not yours
mine i can't change your
past but i can't offer you a purpose
for 600 years our ninja had brought
[Music]
peace
i believe in you
[Music]
all right what do i have to do now
the three challenges of the warrior
if you survive you will gain access to
our knowledge
and our power
[Music]
cobra is coming that's cobra a shadow
organization devoted to global
revolution
i've been following you for some time do
i know you
i know you snake eyes
join us
[Music]
[Music]
robert dubois he's in prison for putting
superman in the icu with a kryptonite
bullet i'm not joining you suicide squad
we'll see my court date is coming up
and miss waller said maybe you could
help me out you're threatening my door
out everyone stand down
down
[Music]
i wouldn't take such extreme measures
this mission went more important than
you could possibly imagine
are you in or out good
let's meet your team it's okay i'm not
okay each member has chosen for his or
her own completely unique set of
abilities
hey guys sorry i'm late let's go number
two good to know
is this thing a dog a dog what kind of
dog do you think it is mate i'm gonna go
with afghan hound
oh my god is it a werewolf you always
tell me there's a widow
let me out yeah he's not a werewolf okay
he's a weasel
he's harmless i mean he's not harmless
he's killed 27 children but
you know
your mission is to destroy every trace
of something known only
as project starfish any questions
starfish is a slang term for a butthole
think there's any connection
no no
all right let's get it
this is suicide well that's kind of our
thing i'm a superhero
i'm going to get you out of here alone
[Music]
stay off the comp
[Music]
jurassic world dominion experience a
special extended preview only on f9 and
[Music]
imax
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no
i can't see you shake my hand
[Music]
um
my grandmother was right the boogeyman
was real
it's over we can't hurt anyone ever
again one told you
told me what somebody in there
[Music]
michael myers
stop you had a knife in your stomach you
and allison
should not have to keep running evil
dies tonight
i'm not just gonna sit and watch another
innocent person die if you track
michael's victim
that's a straight line to michael's
childhood home
what do we do we let's hunt fight down
michael myers is flesh and blood
but a man couldn't have survived that
fire
the more he kills the more he transcends
he's the essence of evil
[Music]
i'm coming for you michael
the truth is
[Music]
it's lonely at the top uncle's head
that's my girl
my baby brother ted all he cares about
is work but he always remembers to send
inappropriately lavish gifts on special
occasions
good night uncle ted i hope to grow up
and be a success just like you
good night tabitha don't you think i'm a
little old for that now
okay i'm afraid tabitha and i are
growing apart
like i did with my brother but you can't
turn back time can you
easy breezy taco easy boys
doesn't last forever but family sure
does hey we get on with this
i miss my teeth what's stressing you out
so much
my dad embarrassed of him oh it's not
that
i just wanted to be proud of me what
i will be there and you and i will
always be brothers makes me want to make
a sad
face
the formula only lasts 48 hours
we always stick together and that's what
families do
who wants to play shawshank on my signal
unleash
the difference in try and triumph
is just a little oh i need options
we did it i guess we did i was talking
about me and precious
oh oh
gross
[Music]
throughout my life the ten rings
gave our family power
if you wanted them to be yours one day
you have to show me you are strong
enough to carry them
you are a product of all who came before
you
the legacy of your family you are your
mother
and whether you like it or not you are
also your father
i told my men they wouldn't be able to
kill me if
they tried
glad i was right
just a criminal who murders people
be careful how you speak to me
i thought i boys change my name start a
new life
but i could never escape his shadow
my son you can't run from your past
[Applause]
is this what you wanted
you got this
thank you
he walk around handing out candy to the
neighborhood kids
one day a couple of kids get razor
blades in their candy
police come around that's when i saw the
true face of fear
get on your knees hands hands
they beat him killed him
a couple weeks later more razor blades
and more candy
he'd been innocent so he's real candy
man ain't
he candy man's the whole damn hive
if you're out here looking for candy man
you ask me
stay away
i feel really connected to this story
god
right here in this neighborhood the
legend started uh-huh
and the legend is if we say his name
five times while looking in the mirror
we could summon him
summon the candy man hell no
candy man anthony nose candy man
i don't want to get creeped out in my
new apartment before bed
black people don't need to be summoning
no i dare you don't say that
you better not do that last one you want
to be a part of the story right no
say his name candy man
anthony anthony
anthony are you okay
the hell is going on this neighborhood
is haunted
i think i made a mistake i brought him
back candyman
isn't real he told me he has purpose for
you
new to the neighborhood you should say
candyman say his name
what do you want from me what do you
want from me
what are you wondering why do you know
why are you scared
[Applause]
[Applause]
stop i need big shows big ideas hey
i have a big one with click hello whoa
you
know calloway clay callaway is a recluse
no one's seen it for 15 years
i'll give you three weeks to get this
show up and running i won't let you down
sir better not or i'll throw you off the
roof
there's nothing holding me back
i have dreamt of performing in red shore
city since i was a little kid
there's nothing holding me
[Music]
this is my daughter portia she wants to
meet calloway big fan my sister is on
her way to meet him right now
[Music]
your destination is on the right on the
right
if okay could just give me some dance
lessons you will be saving my life how
do i know that you're not a waiter
how do i know that you're legit
[Music]
go crazy first take all my baby there's
nothing holding me back
i knew you were a widow play back he
says that she's never
afraid and here she is the star of our
show rosita
oh my gosh can i try no no no no
she's afraid she'll never be able to
play the part maybe this is for the best
i'll write you another part
there he is clay calloway go away
don't you miss the music you just need
to play again
no i can't i haven't even heard one of
my songs
in over 15 years and for good reason
i have climbed the highest
mountains i have run
through the field it's okay
your songs will carry you
just sing what i'm looking forward
that's to i always said right
[Music]
there's always a choice just never have
the guts to make the right one
activating piggy power
first time i fell in love
[Music]
woke up next to the girl
[Music]
and escaped fast and far
an end has changed to me when i see in
her it
is obvious what she sees in me
hmm that's a little more puzzling
one two three four
so maybe
[Music]
this is my baby
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's nothing sacred to you
[Music]
[Music]
everything will be all right
if you were me would you rather live in
legrand or new york city that happened
to love lagrange so
uh what does legrand have exactly
nothing what does new york city have
it has broadway and gaga yeah lady gaga
don't do it don't do what listen to me
when i say
you're beautiful and you're way cause
god makes no mistakes
you're on the right track baby i was
born this way
excuse me i didn't know you knew the
world don't hide yourself from regret
just love yourself and you're set
i'm on the right track baby i was born
this way all right we're not doing that
again
hey dad can i talk to you for a minute
i'm getting picked on by these guys at
school why is that
because i'm not like that there's got to
be more than that why aren't you like
this i'm different
that's not an answer jaden cause i'm gay
we we'll let nature take its course all
right it'll work itself out you know
what it's not going to work itself
[Applause]
what about therapy i don't need therapy
they do talking
on your shirt
trying to hide inside of it you don't
know what it's like hide how
much it hurts to muster up the courage
to ask for help
[Music]
knew before he died that you loved him
and accepted them that's what matters
i never let him know it was okay i got
to live with that
i decided to walk across america i'll
talk to anybody
about bullying when i told you to take a
walk i met around the block not to new
york city
he told us he won't live there someday
remember i saw
he's right there in front of me
god queens are everywhere now can we
turn that off
that wasn't even an appetizer but i have
to deal with day in and day out well
that's cause you're in everybody's face
about it i wonder where i got that one
from
there's a lot of things i've learned out
here nobody but me for company
i still feel jaden's presence
i still got a long road ahead of me
[Music]
my name is peter and that's my sister
ann we had just moved to a new home when
our lives changed forever
hello mr bug we have to go to the moon
and hold on
where's my sister i am afraid
gotcha she's been kidnapped at sunrise
my moon cannon will be ready
and then i will rule over the whole
universe we will
what i will not leave my sister here all
alone
when the sun comes up nobody will be
able to return what's all this stuff for
her for the trip
to the moon now to the caribbean
well of course it's to the moon to the
moon
a journey like this it's for real big
and strong
ah there they are the good the bug in
the other
[Music]
my big brother will be here to free me
soon
he's really gonna come and get you of
course
he's my brother
[Music]
one small step for a beetle one giant
leap
for beetle kind
[Music]